ja willkommen zurück zur Vorlesung
Philosophie der virtuellen Realität
jetzt befassen wir uns ganz konkret mit
einem ästhetischen virtuellen
Objekt
nämlichable Token und ich sag doch ein
bisschen was anknüpfend
sind ein nicht austauschbares das heißt
individuelles und einmaliges digitales
Unikat es lässt sich in Analogie zu
einem physischen Unikat verstehen Kunst
hat häufig nicht immer aber oft den
Anspruch zumindest nur begrenzt
verfügbar sein es hat auch den Anspruch
von Exklusivität
und das digitale ist ja gerade
eigentlich nicht das exklusives und des
Körpers
ja identisch kopierbar das erlauben
digitale Daten sind nur 0,1 Programm hat
so und so viele Kombination von 1 wenn
ich diese Kombination noch mal
publizieren dann habe ich genau dasselbe
Programm genau dasselbe Bild genau
denselben Ton wäre natürlich das
Ausgabegerät identisch ist was dann
wiederum nicht so gut möglich ist
das heißt dadurch dass die digitale
eigentlich keine materiellene Struktur
ist sondern einen
Informationsstruktur kann ich hier eine
ganz andere Logik zugrunde liegen
nämlich die Logik
das identischen vielfältiger identischen
fälligkeitsmöglichkeit
und das ist im physischen so nicht der
Fall
das heißt die Individualisierung die
Kunst erfordert häufig nach dem
traditionellen Verständnis zumindest die
stellt in der Sphäre der Digitalität
oder Digitalisierung Digitalität man die
digitale Lebenswelt eine besondere
Herausforderung da die Digitalisierung
eine Tendenz hat Unikate zu vermeiden
und jetzt wollen wir uns hier gleich mal
ein kurzes Video gemeinsam anschauen
es handelt sich wie immer um eine
Reportage und wir schauen uns diese
Reportage unter folgenden Fragen wir
wollen es ja immer noch analytisch
behandeln welche Arten von nfts gibt es
da werden so ein paar vorgestellt
was ist überhaupt ein NFC sie suchen sie
mal darauf zu achten was diese Frau dann
den Film diese Expertin dazu sagt dann
aber bei uns in Frage die uns vor allem
interessiert wie oder wie virtualisieren
nFC ist die bisher gekommen wenn
auch immer das ist wenn die
wirkliche virtuelle Kunst sein soll dann
müssen sie nach unserer Definition
herkömmliche Form von Kunst eigentliche
Form von uns ursprüngliche Form von
Kunst virtualisieren also im Rahmen
eines neuen Mediums auf neue Weise
realisieren und zwar so dass neue
Möglichkeiten hinzu
damit hängt die Frage zusammen welche
Vorteile bieten nfcs gegenüber der
bisherigen Kunst wir haben gesehen wenn
etwas virtualisiert wird es neue
Vorteile wie Verkehr
und das ist auch bei nfps der war achten
Sie mal genau drauf welche neuen
Möglichkeiten es gibt und vor allem
achten Sie darauf wie sich die Rolle des
Künstlers bzw der Künstlerin ändert was
ändert sich für die unter der Bedingung
der Wirtschaft Realität und nicht zum
Schluss wollen wir uns die Frage stellen
worin besteht das ästhetische von nfcs
ist das überhaupt noch Kunst würden
viele sagen ist das nicht nur digitale
Spielerei diese Frage wollen uns ja auch
genau anschauen und ich starte jetzt mal
gleich die
Video Präsentation und sie achten drauf
wenn es zu laut ist wird man das ganze
dann korrigieren
wir hatten gesehen anhand dieses Videos
dieser Reportagen das nfts mit guten
Gründen als Formen virtueller Kunstwerke
gelten können nach unseren Begriffen
weil sie herkömmliche physisch gebundene
Form von Kunst vor allem bildender Kunst
ins digitale transformieren als
entkörperlichen
entmaterialisieren die selbe Funktion
waren und zugleich neu
Funktionen neue Möglichkeiten öffnen
diese neuen Möglichkeiten betreffen vor
allem das Verhältnis von
Künstlerinnen und Künstler zum
Objekt sie betreffen aber auch den
finanziellen Aspekt von Kunst der immer
mehr ins Zentrum gerückt und das ist
deswegen der Fall weil
nfts über die digitale Struktur verfügen
die eben auch digitalen Währungen zu
kontrollieren und wir haben gesehen dass
Währungen das Geld des Paradigma für
wirtschaftliche Realität ist und wenn
Kunst mit Geld zusammenhängt dann lässt
sie sich natürlich auch sehr leicht
virtualisieren wir haben uns gefragt
unterwegs in Bedingungen sollte man sich
noch
sollte man sich überhaupt nft-kunst
kaufen das hängt ganz entschieden davon
ab wie man zum virtuellen Handlungsraum
steht wenn man sich dort häufig aufhält
wenn man es als lebensweltlichen Faktor
ansieht dann kann natürlich auch
virtuelle Kunst eine konsequente Folge
Zahlen in dieser digitalen Lebenswelt
sich damit zu brüsten damit auch
anzugeben wie es celebrities tun auf
Instagram
oder aber auch eben um sie anderen zu
zeigen
das hängt ganz entschieden davon ab wie
man zum virtuellen Handlungsraum steht
wenn man sagt das ist eh nur eine
Spielerei dann wäre natürlich auch
mft-kunst eine Bluse Spielerei eine
teure über dies sind also entschieden
von unseren Bewertungen ab aber so viel
können wir sagen NFC sind dann genuine
echter guter Kandidat für virtuelle
Kunst sie genügen uns sind fünf
Definition Kriterium
für
Virtualität verwirrtütet sie
virtualisieren materiell gebunden Kunst
es kam jetzt die Frage auf welche Rolle
spielt künstliche Intelligenz bei
virtueller Kunst und deswegen gehen wir
jetzt auf die nächste Frage ein KI und
Kunst ich möchte ihn jetzt hier ein paar
Beispiele bringen
an denen sie sehen wie schon künstlichen
Intelligenz in bildende Kunst zumindest
aber auch ein Tonkunst werden wir gleich
sehen einbezogen wurde und was das für
unser Kunstverständnis ändert vielleicht
kennen Sie dieses Bild
das ist das Porträt auf admon de bölami
wissen Sie wer es gemalt hat raten Sie
mal wer das gemalt haben könnte
wenn ich jetzt zur Frage rembrand es ist
zumindest im Stile hier unten steht auch
irgendwas ganz kryptisches
sieht nichts aus als ob da irgendwie ein
Künstler eine Künstlerin sich von Hand
signiert hätte wenn Sie genau hinschauen
sie das auch aus müssen ein Algorithmus
das merkwürdig man erkennt auf diesem
Bild einen Mann mit weißen Kragen leicht
verschwommenen Augen angedeutet Nase
Mund ein Mantel des wirkt wie eine
Person aus 19 Jahrhundert nicht aus
Mittelalter vielleicht auch nicht aus
dem 20 Jahrhundert so wirkt es jetzt
sage ich ihm den Titel und jetzt muss
ich sehen täuschen dann es ist von einer
KI gemacht worden gar nicht von einer
natürlichen Person und es hat am 25
Oktober 2018 im Auktionshaus Christie's
über 400.000 US-Dollar erzählt
und das Bild wurde eben erstellt mittels
eines Algorithmus und der sieht so aus
das war auch diese Unterschrift unter
diesem Bild
wenn man sich damit genauer beschäftigt
stellt man folgendes fest das war eine
komplexe Algorithmus der war zweigeteilt
ein Generator und ein Diskriminator was
heißt das System wurde mit 15.000
Porträts aus dem Zeitraum von 14 bis 20
Jahrhundert gefüttert
aus dieser Summe wurden
Bilder generiert und der Diskriminator
sollte dann sagen erkennen ob es sich
dabei um ein künstliches oder von
Menschen gemacht das Bild handelt
also das gibt KI hat sich selbst
zusammen überprüft ob sie selbst noch
sich selbst erkennt
ja also auf Basis dieser Portraits ist
weil die Datenbasis seine Gewalt gebaut
haben Basis hat der Generator immer
wieder neue Bilder generiert durch
Vermischungen von Elementen in der
Diskriminator wurde darauf trainiert
künstlich erzeugte Bilder von Menschen
erzeugen Bilder zu unterscheiden
oder zwei Trainingssysteme wurden
aufeinander bezogen und dort wurde
Diskriminator nicht mehr sagen konnte
dieses von KI erstellt oder von
Menschenhand da entstand das Bild also
das ist ein Bild was die KI selbst für
menschlich gehalten hat oder nicht für
ki-mäßigkeiten wenn Ihnen interessante
ästhetische auch wieder eine Meta
ästhetische Dimension des ki-kunst
selbst darauf befragt wird ob sie
menschenähnlich ist
ja das Besondere dieses Porträts was sie
jetzt da gesehen haben besteht darin
dass es
von der menschlichen
Vorstellung eines Porträts aus dem 18
Jahrhundert ein bisschen abweicht denn
es hat etwas zeitgenössisches an sich
und ähnelt den Bildern von Glen Brown
vielleicht kennen so sind zehn dessen
das sind Bilder aus
also er hat mich auch so ein bisschen
in verschiedenen Stil
das hat ein bisschen moderner obwohl ich
hätte jetzt im 19 Jahrhundert angesiegt
jetzt wollen wir auch noch ein bisschen
weiter gehen und uns mal
es war so vor einigen Jahren total in
Mode
machen wir Mode Philosophie hoffentlich
nicht
eine künstliche Intelligenz hat
Beethovens zehnte Sinfonie die war
unvollendet vollendet als Beethoven im
Jahr 1727 stark gehörten zu seinem
Nachlass 40 Kissen meine zehnte
Unvollendete
ein Team von Experten für Maschinen und
Musikwissenschaften nutzte dieses Kissen
um eine KI zu entwickeln wie das für ihn
könnte das Leben von seiner Zeit nicht
gelangt und die Herausforderung bestimmt
dahin
ein musikalisches Thema über mehrere
Taktik entwickeln zu lassen und es auch
sie auch variieren zu lassen
dazu wurde die KI auch trainiert diesmal
nicht mit Bilddaten somit tundaten und
zwar erst wieder junge Beethoven das
heißt sie haben versucht die KI in diese
Zeit
entwicklungsgeschichten hinein zu betten
wie der Junge Beethoven würde es erst zu
tun also im Kontexte Musik des 18
Jahrhunderts der Klasse
Mozart Heiden
vielleicht auch wach und dann wurde sie
auch ins eigenes werden
zunächst wurde die generelle Melodie
produziert und dann von einer anderen
die Harmonisierung und Registrierung
dieser Melodie als auch da sind die
wurde zweigeteilt wurde in sich
gespalten wie bei diesem Bild der
Generator der Diskriminator so wurde
hier die generelle Melodie die
Oberstimme und dann noch die
Harmonisierung
und jetzt wollen sie natürlich bestimmt
wissen wie lange geht diese durch kann
ihn
ja nicht kennt sich neu aber zumindest
komplimentierte oder vervollständigte
Sinfonie
spielen kann
und so weiter und so fort ich merke sie
sind nicht
aus den Hockern gehauen worden ich sehe
nicht in ihren Gesichtern
musikalische Verzückung
wir werden jetzt gleich darüber
diskutieren wie sie dieses Musikstück
bewerben was da ihre Eindrücke sind und
vergleichen Sie Ihren ästhetischen
Eindruck den Sie von dieser Musik dieser
Tonkunst haben von Ihrem Eindruck dieses
Gemäldes von der KI oder würde mich
interessieren finden Sie bei
Einstimmungen zwischen beiden Bildern
obwohl sehr verschiedene Kunstarten
darstellen oder wenn sie sagen es ist
also kaum mehr zu unterscheiden von
menschliche Kunst
wir haben darüber diskutiert über den
ästhetischen Status und viele von ihnen
sagen dass sei nicht sehr beeindruckend
gewesen sie vermissen das
originelle innovative beim späten
Beethoven das klang er wird Potpourri so
best of Beethoven aus allen möglichen
Sinfonien in einen Topf geworfen dreimal
rumgerührt und das kam dabei heraus also
zumindest Originalität haben sie gesagt
konnten sie nicht vernehmen und das
spricht auch einiges dafür
man muss sich fragen ob die Datenbasis
vielleicht nicht gut genug war ob
vielleicht zu wenig Anhaltspunkte waren
wir haben gesehen es gab nur Skizzen von
der 10 Sinfonie man muss sich fragen ob
die Algorithmen vielleicht noch besser
hätten sein können
wir hätten vielleicht noch mehr
originelle Algorithmen gebraucht können
Algorithmen originell sein und diese
Frage die möchte ich jetzt noch weiter
mit ihm diskutieren anhand von
künstlichen Intelligenz verstanden als
virtuelle Muße
kennen Sie Roman Lipski wer kennt den
von Ihnen hier schon ein Nicken nutzt
jedenfalls längst ein KI-System das mit
maschinellen lernen algoriten arbeitet
als große er füttert ist mit seinen
eigenen Bildern und die Maschinen nach
unterbrechen im Vorschläge wie seine
aussehen könnte
da wäre dann unsere Mensch-Maschine
Interaktion KI ist immer eingebetteten
Mensch Maschine Interaktionen nicht so
zu verstehen dass die Maschine das
ersetzt was der Mensch eigentlich tun
sollte
sondern sie wird als Ergänzung oder als
Buße als virtuelle Musik sprich
Inspirationsquelle genutzt und das finde
ich jetzt sehr sehr spannend das heißt
die Mensch-Maschine Interaktion kann
auch unter einer ästhetischen
Perspektive betrachtet werden Mensch
Maschinen Interaktion wird ja häufig vor
allem unter ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten
überhaupt unter technischen
Gesichtspunkten verstanden hier kann man
es auch mal unter ästhetischen
Gesichtspunkten verstehen KI findet
Eingang in alle möglichen Praktiken
es handelt sich so meine Begrifflichkeit
um ästhetische interobjektivität in der
Objektivität bedeutet nicht in der
Subjektivität er ist kein Subjekt ist
ein Objekt eine Maschine wir treten aber
mit der Maschine eine Kommunikation die
nicht so trivial ist wie das Verhältnis
von Menschen und Werkzeug sondern das
Werkzeug steht mit uns in einer
Verbindung die viel intimer ist als wie
wenn ich ein Hammer nehmen würde warum
weil die KI auf mich reagiert seine
Feedback Schleife und das würde ich als
interobjektivität bezeichnet Kunst
schaffen die und künstliche Intelligenz
verhalten sich nicht wie Subjekt und
Objekt oder wie Subjekt meines Erachtens
in solchen
Kooperationen vielmehr bilden sie einen
kreativen Zusammenhang im Sinne
virtueller Kunstproduktion jetzt habe
ich hier behauptet dass es die
Virtualisierung der Kunstproduktion mit
Hilfe von KI ja weil wie könnte das
jetzt eine virtuelle
eine Virtualisierung des kunstprozesses
sein künstliche Intelligenz wird zu
einem virtuellen Muse zu einer
virtuellen Inspirationsquelle durch die
Möglichkeiten der Modifikation
Variationen Transformation von
bestehenden
wird als nicht unbedingt ein Neues
erschaffen sondern bestehendes wird in
überraschende Ordnungen versetzt die ich
sonst selbst mir generieren müsste am
Ende bin natürlich ich
diejenige Instanz die die Kunst
produziert weil künstliche Intelligenz
als solche nicht kreativ ist ja
behaupte ich jetzt mal darüber kann man
wieder streiten aber sie lässt sich in
kreative Prozesse integrieren am Ende
bin ich oder sie die Künstlerin die das
Kunstwerk schafft aber es gibt
verschiedene Mittel oder Möglichkeiten
Wege weisen nur die um künstliche
Intelligenz zu integrieren und dadurch
Kreativität zu steigern
künstlichen Intelligenz kann
Überraschungen und neue Perspektiven
erzeugen die als Inspiration für unser
Kunstschaffen dienen können natürlich
nur dann wenn ich auch das als
Inspirationsquelle erkennen es könnte
Menschen geben die
spannende KI generierte Daten und
Informationen nicht als
Inspirationsquelle wahrnehmen können es
hängt natürlich von meiner Fähigkeit ab
originell ist inspirierendes von weniger
inspirierenden unterscheiden zu können
die KI selbst macht das nicht
zumindest noch nicht
darüber haben wir jetzt auch viel
diskutiert möchte einfach nur die
Debatte werfen
handelt es sich hierbei um die
Virtualisierung von kunstproduktionen
mittels teilen wenn man sagt KI
virtualisiert den
mehr Tiefen Prozess KI virtualisiert die
Ideenfindung ist wieder
präsentproblematisch wie bei dem
Beispiel der Sprache ja ich würde ein
bisschen mich zurückhalten ich würde
nicht das direkt zur formulieren ich
würde sagen es hat auf jeden Fall Moment
von virtuitiv weil wir hier
dieselbe Funktion die sehr dieselbe
Teleologie im Rahmen eines anderen
Mediums der KI realisieren nämlich
Inspiration und es öffnet sich neue
Möglichkeiten also es hat Ansätze wir
müssen mal alle fünf Kriterien abklopfen
ob die darauf zu treffen aber ein paar
Hammer denke ich ja schon
müssen jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen
können sich dann selbst Gedanken noch
dazu machen jetzt möchte ich nämlich zum
lang angekündigten Verhältnis von
Ästhetik der Computerspiele kommt
und zwar muss man sich jetzt erst einmal
fragen was ist überhaupt ein
Computerspiel wer von ihnen spielt ab
und zu Computer
okay also die Hälfte ist gar nicht
schlimm aber sie haben bestimmt schon
mit Computerspielen was zu tun gehabt
noch nie gesehen in einem Monitor ja
gesehen ja genau schnell weiter gelaufen
es gibt ein Buch von Yes
spannenden bezeichnenden Titel half real
nicht half Life das ist der Titel eines
Computerspiels have real Untertitel
video games between real
Birds wir sehen sie wieder die Frage was
ist es Realität Fiktion
illusionssimulation und so weiter die
kommen hier auch zum Tragen und wie der
Titel schon sagt ist computerspiele sind
Halbjahr unsere Aktionen darin sind
Halbjahr
meinte jetzt mit Halbjahr virtuell weil
häufig wird virtuell so Verständnis ist
nicht irgendwie ganz wirklich es ist nur
virtuell sondern einfach uns darauf es
ist
dann würde Mittelstraße kommen und sagen
Konfusion Mode Wahrheit mit halben
Nummern mit halben Dingen können wir uns
in der Philosophie nicht bitten ganz
oder gar nicht real oder nicht ja
Computerspiele scheinen das irgendwie zu
problematisieren ein Video Game ist half
real wie play by real wild imagine
Dragon Folge only in the world
in this short for walking study this the
You
Games das Casting Game von Pong to the
legend of zelda from
Grand Theft
video games
of traditional Electronics hat immer
Verhältnis zu nicht digitalen Spielen zu
Kartenspiel
booking 1 Perspektive
es gibt mittlerweile sogar schon die
Disziplin der Games
du Outliner theory of what video games
the work with the player how the have
develope history and why they are fun to
play
er sagt Computerspiele spielen macht
Spaß okay besteht jetzt der otologische
oder ästhetische Status von
Computerspielen nur darin dass sie Spaß
machen das wäre aber ein bisschen
ärmlich würde ich mal sagen
oder die Antwort auf die Frage warum
Computerspiele philosophisch interessant
sind warum wir Sie in diesem Seminar
behandeln in dieser Vorlesung behandeln
sollten weil sie Spaß machen es wäre
vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig ich
würde jetzt mal sagen sie sind deswegen
so spannend weil sie nicht ganz
eindeutig undologisch bestimmbar sind
damit hängt natürlich auch ethischer und
ihr ästhetischer Status zusammen sagt
wir machen jetzt ein bisschen auch das
was er macht wir beginnen jetzt auch
bald bei Pong und geben so ein bisschen
eine Geschichte dieses
Mediums das müssen wir überhaupt noch
diskutieren Computerspiel überhaupt
Medien
meine Frage
Computerspiele und Philosophie muss ich
noch davor Fragen verträgt sich das
überhaupt Computerspiele hier diese
ehrwürdigen
Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität einer
Vorlesung zu behandelt schlimm genug
dass wir uns überhaupt mit der
virtuellen Realität befassen und der
Jürgen Mittelstraße sagt sie sei nicht
die Domäne der Wissenschaft ja jetzt
trage ich sie in diese Heeren Hallen
hinein und setzt ihm noch eins drauf
oder eins drunter vielleicht besser wenn
wir jetzt noch Computerspiele werden es
gibt verschiedene Vorteile oder auch
berechtigte Einwände computerspiele sind
nur was verloren das sind sie alle nicht
Computerspiele machen süchtig
Computerspiele machen süchtig muss ich
jetzt aufpassen ihn jetzt hier
Computerspiele zu präsentieren weil sie
am Ende süchtig werden und morgen nicht
mehr die letzte Vorlesung deswegen
kommen können weil sie die ganze Nacht
durchgezockt haben
Computerspiele ein weiteres verurteil
machen aggressiv wobei da schon auch die
Psychologie unterschiedlicher Meinung
ist billerspiele und Amokläufe sind
leider häufig in einem gewissen Kontext
zu finden und das Verhältnis muss man
natürlich auch genau erklären ist es
eine kausale Relation oder eine
Verbindung
davon die nicht kausal zu verstehen ist
Korrelation
oder Kausalitäten das überlassen wir
lieber mal der Psychologie hier wo es
gar nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen und
Computerspiele machen dumm ich hoffe
nicht dass ihre Intelligenz die sie hier
mir schon deutlich gezeigt haben jetzt
im Folgenden folgenden Minuten darunter
leiden wird weil diese These hat Manfred
Spitze vertreten digitale Demenz die wir
uns in unsere Kinder um den Verstand
bringen zum Glück sind sie alle keine
Kinder mehr dann können wir uns
können wir uns sozusagen davor schützen
meine These ist kommt natürlich darauf
an wie man computerspielt sich mit allem
der Gebrauch macht das
braucht man nicht länger darauf eingehen
wie ein Thema einer anderen Sitzung ich
mache oben rechts ein Video rein wo ich
den mal ein bisschen ausführlicher
nachgegangen bin und jetzt möchte ich
wie versprochen in eine kurze
Evolutionsgeschichte des Computerspiels
präsentieren wir beginnen mit diesem
Spiel wer hat dieses Spiel schon mal
gespielt wer spielt es sogar noch ja das
sie kennen das alle ähm das ist vor über
50 Jahren schon erschienen die ersten
Varianten gibt es 60er 70ern wissen Sie
wie das Spiel heißt mit Sicherheit
wissen sie
von 1972 es gibt aber noch eine ältere
Version können Sie alles im Internet
nachlesen ja natürlich setzt das die
Entwicklung des Computerspiels Hardware
voraus die gebrauchsfähig ist das kann
natürlich nicht in den 20er Jahren
verstanden worden sein ja weil es da
noch nicht Computer in dieser Art
jedenfalls gab es war ein Folgen des
Zweiten Weltkriegs hat sich auch die
Computerindustrie extrem entwickelt in
den 50er Jahren 60ern und da wo eben
Technologien nur entwickelt wird da wird
auch immer gespielt mit der Technologie
also computerspiele sind immer eine
Reflexion auf Technologie sind nicht nur
Technologie ich würde sogar so weit
gehen und sagen sie sind nicht nur
Medien sind Reflexionen auf Mädchen ich
habe eine medial selbstreflexiven
Dimension jetzt frage ich sie ist das
ein virtuelles Tischtennisspiel
diese Debatte habe ich mit David geführt
er meinte nicht jetzt wörtlich auf
dieses Spiel bezogen auf bricks
vielleicht kennen Sie dieses Spiel auch
bricks
etwas wird traurig ist ich habe gesagt
das ist nur eine Simulation
das Tischtennis aber schwierig
weil der Zweck ist ja eigentlich schon
ähnlich ne
wird der das Spiel jetzt simuliert oder
wird es virtualisiert das echte
Tischtennis spielen
ja spannend ist wirklich spannend wir
müssen einfach mal dahingestellt sein
lassen andere Frage handle ich wenn ich
jetzt mal die rechte Position bin und
dieses Ding hier hoch und runter schiebe
während des Links der Computer immer
handle ich da ist eine Handlung
auch nicht so leicht zu sagen ist
überhaupt spielen eine Handlung würde
man schon sagen ja
spannend wird es jetzt wenn hier links
nicht ein Computer geht ist sondern eine
andere Person ändert sich dann der
ontologische Status meine These war erst
dann ist es keine Simulation mehr wenn
zwei Menschen miteinander spielen dann
ist es ein vielleicht ein virtuelles
Spiel aber wenn solange deinen
computergegen ist ist meine Simulation
meine Intuition müssen wir nicht genau
bestimmen darüber können andere
Generationen ihre Doktorarbeiten
schreiben ich möchte nur zu bedenken
dass es auch hier ontologische Konfusion
gibt wenn man überhaupt sich diese Frage
stellen möchte und nicht einfach nur
Spaß haben möchte beim Spielen viele
würden sagen lass mich doch einfach
Punkt spielen ist doch egal ob ich diese
simuliere virtualisiere hauptsache ich
habe meinen Spaß
okay jetzt kommt natürlich mein geheimt
wenn Sie das Erraten dann sind sie gut
und diese Spiel heißt wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr
es ist
command der Kinn
91 das habe ich gespielt
so sieht das Cover aus wer von ihnen hat
eine Switch wo jetzt Frage ich habe
persönliche Sachen und das wird
Spielekonsole
wenn Sie eine Switch haben haben Sie
Glück weil es gibt die definitive
Edition von diesem Spiel aus dem Jahr
1991 programmiert für heutige Endgeräte
bereit Bild und sie sind alle über sechs
Jahre sehe ich hier das heißt Sie dürfen
das auch ganz legal spielen USK ab sechs
Jahre freigegeben ja super also falls
sie sich keine Switch falls Sie noch
keine Switch Nintendo Switch Spiele
Konsole haben wäre das mal jetzt eine
Überlegung wäre dass ihnen
dreams es geht um einen Jungen der räumt
von bösen Gemüse welches Kind würde das
nicht machen wenn es wieder so etwas
angeboten bekommt mittags ja
sicherlich würden nicht currywursten
ohne Currywurst und Pommes in diesen
Träumen vorkommen weil das sind ja
Albträume keine Albträume alles Gemüse
jagt diesen kommandit sie haben gesehen
aggressive Tomaten Kartoffeln und so
weiter ich finde sie ganz originelle
Story ganz amüsant deswegen auch ab 6
Jahren freigegeben
schauen sich mal das hier an
sieht ja richtig fotorealistisch aus
könnte praktisch wirklich eine Aufnahme
einer echten Welt sein ist es aber nicht
es ist die an real Engine 5 der neueste
Schrei der Technologien und sie sehen
was hier auffällt die Licht und Schatten
geben extrem realistische schattengebung
ist das jetzt eine virtuelle Welt nee
ist eine simulierte Welt hochgradig
realistisch aber simuliert das ist die
Unreal Engine 5 dieses Sequenz haben Sie
schon mal gesehen aus Meta hier gibt's
jetzt stärker opented reality wo also in
die physische Welt virtuelle Elemente
hineingezogen werden simulieren die
jetzt Tischtennis zu spielen oder
spielen die wirklich sagen
ist eine Virtualisierung die irgendwie
auch noch augmented realisiert ist
ja einige Infos zu Computer spielen aber
auch nur kurz Computerspiele werden mal
realistischer einerseits stimmt es
andererseits ist zu beobachten dass es
den Retro Trend gibt es gibt den Trend
back to the roots back to Pong und so
weiter und so fort Pixel Art ja wo man
in den 2000er Jahren noch gelacht hat
wenn der Pixel kennbar waren
mittlerweile 20 Jahre später gibt es
Spiele die diesen pixel-look als eigene
Ästhetik wiederum auf dem Bildschirm
bringen aber trotzdem werden sie immer
realistischer bald können wir computer
simulation nicht mehr von der Realität
unterscheiden das ist eine systemisches
Problem wir haben das andere 5 gesehen
und wie bei allem digitalen und auch
virtuellen Computerspiele werden mehr
Tag als Teil unseres Alltags und jetzt
kommts unabhängig von Alter Geschlecht
und Bildung stand und es möchte ich
Ihnen jetzt mal im Folgenden durch ein
paar Statistiken präsentieren es geht
sogar so weit dass Computerspiel machen
Universitäten erforscht werden selbst an
der LMU München undenkbar wenn das die
Gründe gewusst hätten was hier mal 200
Jahre später alles so unterrichtet wird
aber zum Glück dürfen wir das ja
Freiheit in Forschung und Lehren man
dafür unterrichten was man will sofern
Sie mit dem Grundgesetz irgendwie anders
Konfrontation Gerät so jetzt dürfen sie
mal überlegen wie das Durchschnittsalter
der computerspielerinnen Spieler er ist
wie viel Jahre sie denken und Sie werden
staunen es ist 38 Jahre so jung ist man
gar nicht wenn man Computer spielt
was fällt auf das Alter mit Ausnahme von
2014 ist kontinuierlich gestiegen
immer mehr ältere wirken Schichten
erreicht genauso auch der Anteil 54%
aller Menschen in Deutschland spielen
Computer
was denken Sie mehr Männer oder Frauen
sie denken wahrscheinlich mehr Männer
ist nicht so genau halb 54% männlich und
weiblich da kann man mit einigen
Vorurteilen auf
Räumen und jetzt könnte ich mir
überlegen mich Altersschicht am
häufigsten spielt sie würden
wahrscheinlich sagen die 20 bis
29-Jährigen oder die 10 bis 19 jährigen
falsch
die 50 bis 59-Jährigen zusammen mit den
30 bis 39-Jährigen spielen am häufigsten
auch interessant jetzt dürfen sie mal
raten wie das aussieht mit dem
Bildungsgrad sie würden vielleicht
denken HauptschülerInnen Hauptschüler
falsch mittlere Reife gefolgt von
akademischen Grad
und dann erst Hauptschule dann
Abitur und dann Berufsschule also quer
durch alle Bildungsschichten geht es
hindurch sein breiten wirksames Phänomen
jetzt kann man sich natürlich überlegen
welche Art von Computer spielen werden
häufig gespielt Casual Games sind ganz
vorne aber schauen Sie mal Strategie und
Aufbauspiele das sind komplexe Spiele
die brauchen viel Zeit sind auf alle an
der zweiten Stelle
ist nicht irgendwie nur solche
Zeitvertreib spielte das sind die Casual
Games die spiele ich auf der in der
U-Bahn wenn ich mal wieder irgendwie
warten ja aber Strategiespiele Spiele
spiele ich in der Regel nicht am
Smartphone die Spiele nicht auf
stationär oder zumindest 10 Minuten ja
Fitness Bewegungsspiele haben wir
gesehen kann man auch mit Beate Technik
realisieren und so weiter und so fort
auf welchen Geräten spielt man ähm
häufigsten Smartphone das war klar
Laptop aber auch und spielt sie mobil
und Tablet auch der stationäre PC wird
immer selten benutzt
das liegt natürlich ganz im Trend der
Mobilität
ja auch innerhalb von Computerspielen
werden immer mehr
beharren abgesetzt die sind sogenannte
Mikrotransaktionen man gibt nicht immer
nicht mehr nur Geld aus für das Spiel
sondern auch im Spiel selbst das deutet
darauf hin dass es sich bei hierbei auch
in virtuelle Realitäten handelt
virtuelle Marktplätzen man kann
virtuelle Gegenstände im Computer
spielen kaufen zum Beispiel bei Diablo 4
kann man Rüstungen kaufen und so weiter
und so fort natürlich ist es auch immer
ein bisschen Abzocke das möchte ich dir
gar nicht in Abrede stehen
das muss man auch immer natürlich
bedenken das ist hier auch ganz stark
ökonomische Interessen gibt
was hat jetzt Computerspiele mit
Philosophie zu tun
es kommt natürlich immer darauf an was
wir unter Computer spielen verstehen
darüber möchte ich mit Ihnen auch gleich
diskutieren es kommt darauf an wie wir
Computerspiele spielen und es kommt
darauf warum wir Computer
auf die erste Frage ein was verstehen
wir eigentlich unter Computerspielen und
das wollen wir auch unsere Thematik hier
in der Vorlesung zurückziehen ist
Computer spielen irgendwie eine Sache
von Virtualität oder virtuelle Realität
oder ist es nur eine Sache Simulation
gebe ich Ihnen so ein paar mögliche an
ein Computerspiel ist ein Spiel
es wäre eine Möglichkeit und da möchte
ich auf diesen netten Herrn hier
verweisen auf Friedrich Schiller der
sagt nämlich der Mensch spielt nur wohl
ein voller Bedeutung des Wortes Mensch
ist und er ist nur da ganz Mensch du
erspielt
was hat es mit dem Spiel auf sich ist
spielen nur so eine nutzlose Spielerei
oder kommt dem Spiel nicht doch noch ein
bisschen mehr zu
schiller hat die Überzeugung dass wir
wenn wir spielen frei sind und diesen
Freiheitsgedanken wollen wir jetzt auch
noch mal heute auf den Begriff der
virtuellen Realität beziehen
Kunst ist eine Form von Freiheit
ja widmen uns dadurch der Kunst dass wir
freiwesen sind Kreativität ist eine Form
von Freiheit wir spielen wenn wir frei
sind und wie spielen wir wir spielen mit
der Wirklichkeit den wir sie simulieren
und das tun wir natürlich in der Kunst
auf jeden Fall wir simulieren
fingieren Dinge nicht nur aber wir
reflektieren die Wirklichkeit Kunst
reflektiert die Wirklichkeit ohne ein
ganz konkreten Zweck dabei haben zu
müssen Kunst ist auch in Form des Spiels
durchaus
verständlich wir spielen aber nicht nur
mit der Wirklichkeit sondern wir spielen
auch mit uns im Computer spielen indem
wir zum Beispiel andere Rollenspielen so
kann man sich das zum Beispiel im
metaverso vorstellen das ist ein Spiel
ist indem wir aber auch mit uns selbst
spielen wir experimentieren auch mit uns
selbst wie schauen wie wir auf andere
wirken wenn wir nicht mit unseren
physischen Körper präsent sind sondern
mit einem Avatar das sagt natürlich
nicht nur etwas über unsere
Weltverhältnis auf außer virtuelles
Weltverhältnis kann auch über unsere
virtuelles und physisches
selbstverhältnis eine ganz wichtig ist
immer zu betonen dass ich hier um
weltverhältnisse und um
fremdverhältnisse handeln und jetzt will
ich gerne mit ihm diskutieren
inwiefern
Computerspiele Form von virtuelle
Realität sein können und inwiefern der
Gedanke der Freiheit der mit dem Spiel
zusammenhängt sich auch auf virtuelle
Realität anwenden lässt
was haben Freiheit man muss natürlich
immer fragen was Freiheit ist und
virtuelle Realität miteinander gemeint
diese Frage die wir hier zum Abschluss
jetzt diskutieren werden die leitet über
auf die morgige und letzte Vorlesung wo
es um die Anthropologie geht schauen
sich noch mal dieses Zitat an der Mensch
ist nur der spielt nur dort wo denn
volle Bedeutung des Wortes Mensch ist
und er ist nur da ganz Menschen spielen
ich wage jetzt die provokative These
dass der Mensch nur da ganz Mensch ist
wo er auch virtualisiert meine These die
ich morgen vertreten werde ist die das
die Anthropologie
über den Begriff der virtuellen
virtuellen Realität oder der Praxis das
virtualisierens auch besser verständlich
wird der Mensch so meine These ist auch
ganz entschieden durch die Praxis des
virtualisieren kann nicht nur durch das
Spielen virtualisieren im Sinne des
alternativen realisieren es ist
kreativen neuen Realisieren von
bestehenden also gefragt können wir über
den Begriff des virtuellen der
Virtualität auch neue oder interessant
die andere politische Aussagen treffen
die Fragen werden
jetzt diskutieren wir noch zum Schluss
über diese Fragen